p
I'm code Moses mitrani from Uganda I'm a
student at Carnegie Mellon University
Australia cumbers pursuing muscles
officers in public policy and management
they are the important aspect was the
quality of education that was associated
with the the US universities and also
the repetition of those universities
then the other aspect was the employment
opportunities one they can't date vorpal
countries they always look for persons
who are qualified from international
institutions so that one motivated me
also to look for outside output come and
stand outside the country
among us a scholarship until this is a
scholarship is really good are benefited
from it one lap a hundred percent for my
tuition to they also paid they're paying
for my upkeep or mice in Australia
accommodation transport and also out of
pocket
this gives Alfred
like them they will assist my country
they also assist the smallholder farmers
and also asses the country in totality
through an opportunity lat t say we
Africans we should really explore and
utilize